Allisyn feel better take it sleazy
that's the thing I'm saying no take it
sleazy I like it yeah as your newly
appointed leader our first order of wait
guys don't leave yet no wait we haven't
figured out the pajama thing waymond
you stay right there get nap no no no no
no no thanks ha hey guys do you mind
getting back to your desks and making it
a successful work day one we're tossing
them that's it okay maybe not a beer
maybe paperwork hey Jett oh uh so I was
thinking maybe we should do the group
photo soon son we go
hey Blake be honest what is it about me
that no one respects that my hair yeah
I'm thinking about getting a new haircut
changing stuff up maybe getting like an
Arnie Schwarzenegger or jingle all the
way type of haircut you know short tall
and stiff sound like how I like my men